Frank wants to fill up a spherical water
balloon with as much water as possible
the balloons he bought can stretch to a
radius of three inches not too big if
the Ballu if the volume of a sphere is
and this is volume as a function of
radius is equal to 4/3 PI R cubed what
volume of water in cubic inches can
Frank put into the balloon so this
function definition is going if you give
it a radius in inches it's going to
produce a volume in cubic inches so
let's rewrite it volume as a function of
radius is equal to 4/3 PI R cubed now
they say the balloons he bought can
stretch to a radius of 3 inches so let's
think about if the radius gets to 3
inches what the volume of that balloon
is going to be so we essentially would
just input 3 inches into our function
definition so everywhere where we see in
R we would replace it with a 3 so we
could write it just to be clear let me
rewrite it in the same color V of that's
not the same color we do it in that
brownish brownish color right over here
so V of 3 V of 3 is equal to is equal to
4/3 pi instead of R cubed I would write
3 cubed 3 4/3 PI 3 cubed 3 cubed this is
how the function definition works
whatever we input here it will replace
the R in the expression so V of 3 is
going to be equal to so this is going to
be equal to 4/3 pi times 3 to the third
power is 27 27 divided by 3 is 9 so this
is 9 9 times 4 is 36 PI so this is equal
to 36 pi and since this was in inches
our volume is going to be in inches in
inches in inches cubed or cubic inches
so that's the volume of water that Frank
can put in the balloon 36 PI cubic
inches
you